you know another manifestation of that
behavior I think is NATO or the way that
NATO's been behaving by putting military
bases right on the border of countries
and then if the countries get upset and
invade they're like you're the dude you
you can't put turrets in front of
someone's front door and expect that
you're the one that's under attack when
they blow up your turret right like
reasonable response I
yeah they attacked your turret that was
attacking their space by encroaching on
it so like if you you can't that's just
this whole plank getting up in a cop's
face pushing or like you know getting
them to push you and then claiming
you're a victim you got up in the guy's
face if uh if any videos come out this
weekend I urge everyone to pay very
close attention to when that video
starts look for the editing that usually
comes to manipulate how uh how an
interaction started between law
enforcement that's uh always the first
thing you should pay attention to
because it speaks to their desire to uh
push you push you push you until you do
something back and then they have the
the weapon they need